[Music]
[Music]
Phoebe kale salad I'm on page 134
chain-of-command doesn't apply to other
military contractors in the field I will
see why she would lie to us caprese
sandwich when they're in actual combat
whom exactly do your heroes report to
same person as always me spicy chicken
cilantro wrath subheading 16 we need a
top secret Yankee white designation for
compound B I'm stating only one man okay
is that you want to stroll into the Oval
Office and start barking orders oh yes
half our own heroes don't know they have
compound B in their veins you want
trying to find it
[Music]
this one best efforts to limit
collateral damage we'd prefer stronger
wording well a standard language for our
New York contract la Chicago exactly
what edge will be allowance are we
looking at here officially
zero of course but cone of silence 34%
veggie frittata
buh-bingo with model my DC hey to carry
my goodness image it deal in Tibet
Chirac there a bit higher
ah hey Jim litter man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]